[Music]
I'm going to tell you it's so beautiful
that I said to myself a plane is beautiful
but pieces of plane are beautiful
too
[Music]
the customers who enter the store
like I have a tenderness for you  have seen
for the airplane propellers it's people
who think of Brancy but it's people
who simply find it good because
of the reflections
[Music]
Henri did the first kilometer in an
official closed circuit the Wright brothers flew
certainly before but they didn't want to
have witnesses so we
made the first official flight in the world.
I was born after the second war
and my father had been a fighter pilot,
he told us what he
was doing, he told us about the  operations
I don't reassemble the planes to
show the children and others
how they made a plane I
am so admiring of the
planes so in fact I only
continued what was already being done
[Music]